a life cut short the body of 17 year old
muhammad abu salah is taken to be buried
he was killed by israeli forces during
confrontations near janine in the
occupied west bank
the standoff started when the israeli
army arrived to demolish the home of
palestinian prisoner muhammad jaladat
who is accused of fatally shooting an
israeli settler in december
also led to an armed standoff between
palestinian gunmen and the israeli army
the army said quote it identified what
it called a number of armed rioters and
fired toward them to neutralize a threat
hundreds of palestinians are turned out
to protest against the demolition
there's a message here
and that's you know zero tolerance in
other words we the israelis will not
tolerate any kind of
what you call resistance what israel
calls of course terrorism so what it's
trying to do then is to say you're
criminals and any time you
do a violent act israel will never
consider it a resistance act we are
going to come after you
and the idea is to try to intimidate the
palestinians and try to give them the
feeling that there's no space whatsoever
for any kind of resistance to what
israel is doing
israel continues to apply its policy of
home demolitions the palestinians and
human rights groups say accounts to
collective punishment against the
palestinian people stephanie decker
al-jazeera
meanwhile tension remains high in the
flashpoint suburb of sheikh jarrah in
occupied east jerusalem israeli police
cleared protesters on sunday injuring
dozens of people demonstrations broke
out when a far-right israeli mp tried to
reopen a political office
harry fawcett in sheikh what's happening
now harry
well just in the last few minutes we've
seen where there was a group of some
israeli jews
praying and some palestinians
palestinian israelis and palestinians
sort of standing around them and filming
police have just cleared that away so
the street is now
largely empty of such groups although
the one of the palestinian families
here on
over my right shoulder
the salem family facing eviction
potentially next month are still
gathered uh what's been taking place has
been this decision by this far-right
member of the knesset the israeli
parliament itamar bengali
who in response to
a an arson attack the police say on a
local jewish settler home in this area
he came to open a sort of a de facto
open-air office he said to defend the
rights of jewish settlers in the area
there were pretty
sizable confrontations and skirmishes
some violence
overnight
last night during which he tried to get
through a police
sort of barricade when they were trying
to empty the area he collapsed and fell
went to hospital said he'd fainted and
had a medical certificate to prove it
there was some ridicule of him
on on social media sort of calling this
whole thing very performative but it is
nonetheless extremely risky he was back
here again on monday
he is a member of the knesset so he has
parliamentary
immunity he has bad relations with the
current israeli prime minister naftali
bennett a right winger that ben gover
says has been a traitor to the right so
there is less leverage over him to get
him out and there are important
confluence of dates coming up with uh
the jewish passover and ramadan taking
place concurrently
or at the same time rather in april the
potential eviction of this family next
month in march and in the background
hamas in gaza threatening a severe
response to israeli actions in what you
say rightly is a flashpoint area so
we're not quite a year since the last
time that this really really flared up
uh and was a precursor for the uh the
gaza war last may it's not quite at that
level yet but certainly tensions are
building again okay harry fawcett thank
you for that update he's in shaykh
in
east jerusalem